I think wokery is the wrong answer to
some real questions the real questions
are why are certain groups in this
country trapped in poverty why do other
groups continue to dominate society and
continue to get an unfair share of the
rewards of that society and I think
there are certain answers to that
question which can be delivered by
looking at the meritocratic tradition
and modifying it improving it for the
modern world so Lucas has risen somebody
as Peter has said as a way of slaking
our our appetite for for virtue but
partly as incorrect solutions to very
very real problems and I think that we
have to try harder not only to address
these problems but almost a crow that we
are addressing them or we will have
the workers doing what they think
they're doing which is to smuggle in the
pre-modern way of thinking about the
world into modernity a pretty liberal
way of looking at the world which I
think is profoundly unhelpful